un parfum d'asie flotter ce samedi 19 et
dimanche 20 mai au gymnase des droits de
l'homme à guyancourt l'enceinte sportive
accueillez pour la toute première fois
une coupe de france de kung fu pour les
jeunes rendez vous qui a tiré trois cent
soixante compétiteurs ils ont fait la
compétition dans les différentes régions
et ensuite ils ont été qualifiés à dire
ceux qui sont qualifiés s'ils viennent
pour les championnats pour la coupe de
france le jeune est donc là ils viennent
de toute la france et même d'autres
maire de bains qui viennent de
martinique et de guadeloupe de corse
aussi nous avons donc on a nous avons
tous le tout la france et les dom tom
qui sont représentés aujourd'hui sur les
tatamis tous les participants doivent
impressionner les juges avec des figures
réalisées sur plusieurs minutes
nous avons une représentativité de la
pratique qui se fait en france des
styles traditionnels du style et me dit
qu'on appelle un style imitative comme
le tigre le singe la mante religieuse
nous avons des styles comme le style de
shaolin aussi qu'ils sont entrés répondu
qu'ils sont tenues à travers le temple
de shaolin ça c'est les styles à manu
après nous avons style mais stylée les
formats avec arme des techniques que les
jeunes brulent courtois du cqa w dragon
loire le club organisateur connaissent
par coeur
on imagine qu'à plusieurs personnes qui
viennent nous attaquer à la fois
du coup il faut les combattre tous on
donne un coup de pied dans la cheville
où on donne deux coupes ans d'affilée
dans la tête
sinon on fait un saut on donne on donne
un coup de pied là et le piège à rat
pour claquer la coupe de france des
jeunes pourrait revenir en 2019 à
guyancourt le club devrait à nouveau se
porter candidat auprès de la fédération
française
[Musique]